bella tutti i cappelli e benvenuti
questo video sono fa vj oggi siamo su
aim brand mi chiami con l'alzheimer
comunque ragazzi siamo prima eravamo
rimasti che mancava l'ultimo livello
credo credo sia l'ultimo quello del
giardino dove presente devo andare a
tostare il pane in giardino ovviamente
in giardino perché tutti hanno un
tostapane in giardino mi sembra ovvio
piquet ma tosta non ce l'ho fatta
l'ultima volta incredibilmente non so
come vediamo se riesco a farla primo
tentativo
manco per il cazzo ma abbasso le figure
di merda dai forza come si giocano
comunque ragazzi a parte sta che bello
perfetta la madonna sta con via via via
via via via via di aver non è crollato
non è che ora no
[ __ ] è crollato cestino aveva ben
riuscito a far cadere un cestino con un
toast amatemi con che non so bene sto
scivolando lentamente nella morte
[Musica]
ovviamente un toast in giardino sì ho
fatto che visto mi sono salvato non so
come va bene come faccio a tostare un
pezzo di pane in giardino una scuola
macchina devo entrare nel motore non
l'ho capita questa cosa ma ci proviamo
vai in un'edizione no
e vabbè vabbè vabbè dai dati che ci
faccia ce la faccio un pene si no quasi
che abbia stavolta serio mai credo in te
cestino credo nel tuo cuore ma inizia
come faccia che merda e vabbè no madonna
che salto da checa vai così vai no li
mortacci tua mente come ho fatto
approdare nel menu o madonna che è presa
che è presa della madonna
sì sì
skate board della salvezza io rimarrei
solo se tutta la vita velo di corsa ma
iniziare dai niente si sporca il toast
[ __ ] sono morte e niente ragazzi
abbiamo fatto due minuti di video a
cazzo perché non è servito a niente dopo
stata dall'altra parte utile bene è
perfetto che il vero che si sta sui vasi
sporchi di termo perfetto un cazzo basta
che non salì sulla macchina giusto per
madonna che ecco ma ad un hacker ma beh
io bastare dopo questa vado all insù
record un ragazzo abbiamo finito questi
minchia rivasi se dio vuole perché non
ce l'ha non ce la posso più fare la
scala sta ovviamente la scala col tetano
sopra c'è scritto botte tano però la
macchina no è la macchina non si sa ma
lei no
che cazzo fai scala ragazzi alla scala
contro di me lou reed allora latitanti
regala un'altra scala femmina molto
gnocca se per caso rimane ferma brava no
ti stupro la famiglia da chi ha bisogno
discarica sono un toast
io sono un toast e il tosto non ha
bisogno di scalera in [ __ ] caldo
ma lo sapevo che purga che è sta roba
se se dio ti ringrazio è stato tragico
ne voglio più non voglio più toccare
terreno in tutta la mia vita una scatola
di cacciaviti e chiodi avete mai
prodotto il pane con chiodi ragazzini
che una bontà ariano non ci sono
arrivato processo facendo in un modo
incredibile
oh mio dio cosa ho fatto regala cosa ho
fatto non ho parole
dove sono le mie medaglie dote da cazzo
di radio tra l'altro perché si accende
sta roba ti penso a vado al contando
ready for you love di gore non si di
equa siamo sulla fine del mondo su fa
cagare che non la sai fare la radio mi
ti permette di parlare così nonché
ragazzi a parte sta roba stop non sto
avendo dei movimenti degli spasmi verso
la pianta e dovrei riuscire ad arrivare
alla ma come caligola macchina madonna
che addominali stoppa ne vai così vai
fai vedere di che pasta sei fatto
anzi di che farina ne sa qualcosa
leggende e fatti questo patate queste
come faccia salire si può non è che si
può devo se non muoio se già fatta e non
si sporca ragazzi pane patate signoria
ormai scavalco tetti manco spider man
reagan era roba se ce l'ho fatta ragazzi
è stato cos'è
che cazzo c'è un tavolo apparecchiato
l'agio ma perché ho trovato un ma siamo
sicuri che devo tirarlo nella macchina
sottoscala dove c'è qualcos'altro da
fare che non vedo se è una roba
devo buttare giù i mattoni e spaccare la
macchina non so ci provo ragazzi prova
spaccarla ma non so quanto possa aiutare
ma ci provo ma in sé è caduto si è rotto
un cazzo sì sì sì ho rotto tutto si è
rotta la macchina per adesso posso
bruciare no pazzo proprio ragazzo devo
andare che non c'è il barbecue vincere
ho visto barbecue mosche deficiente sono
veramente ma posso passare dalla
macchina mi stuprano vivo mi stuprano
vivo cioè il 22 per cento di vita
ragazzi non rischiano di passare dalla
macchina perché se muoio potrei
incazzarvi leggermente perché non
arriverò mai più nella vita a questo
punto se non finisco adesso non finirò
mai più vai vai vai malizia non ci
arriverò mai ragazzi mi sembra di farmi
l'oceano no non ci credo
no non voglio morire adesso no non li
prego tuo pezzo di f.no rega vi prego
perché back to menu ma perché back to
meno perché mi preciso sembra che mi
stia infilando un vaso [ __ ] è
certo se bel bagno vanta che è successo
non sono vivo sono stato miracolato da
dio ragazzi pane che cammina sulla no
seriamente come ho fatto a definire su
una ninfea cazzo sono ragazzi dove cazzo
ma perche la cosa non fatta finire come
posso godermi queste cose ragazzi toast
zattera è bellissimo è un esemplare di
tosto e molto raro schema di toast
zattera è la madonna che acrobata su
leggo con cosa sono queste commossa via
via dove sta andando dove cazzo valute
figlio mi capitava di fare bungee
jumping con un pezzo di pane
sa cosa mi sono anche a pato io non so
neanche come cosa sto facendo per andare
avanti non mi sto capendo il sarto ho
fatto tutto grande grande così bravo io
no vabbè io non ho parole se vinco sta
partita giro nudo per calcio no no che
tocchi terra un oggetto di terra non ho
toccato terra ragazzi mi sto salvando i
modi improponibili
niente io non so come ho fatto a
salvarmi fino adesso non riuscirei mai
più nella vita mi chiami per tornare gli
anni ragazzi ci ho messo a piano piano
sta come ho fatto a cader prima e no
ragazzi non so come sono caduto però
potrei ripetere lo stesso errore in due
secondi non seriamente come cazzo fatto
a cader dai dai dai
muoviti che se mimica una merda non ci
credo lavori che torni indietro ho visto
cagando posto per minato seriamente
difficilissimi faccio arrivare l'alta
per non no non ad homer giuro che uccido
qualcuno oggi io ma se passo sulla
macchina allora ragazzi provo ci devo
provare per forza perché non riesco a
passare sul muro ci prova 3 2 1 ti prego
dio non si sporca kat
ho visto la vita passarmi dalla non ci
posso credere ragazzi ascolani hardin
abruzzesi storica importante in un tocco
le merde perfetto grandissimo mi amò da
solo per risparmiami la morte
incredibile anche prima allora
[ __ ] saperlo ce l'ho fatta
mi sono aggrappato corso come avuto una
cagata cellophane mio dio gli anni per
arrivare qua ragazzi amica mezz'ora
buongiorno tazze tutto bene tutto a
posto lui de stronzo voi siete partite
vicine giusto vi uccido ecco piano
buttalo giù che sei forte minchia la
palestra si vede che cosa è successo al
mio ragazzi sto perdendo il grip placè
veloce su no no no no mutado li mortacci
tua son caduto non ci credo se muoio 5
per cento veloce veloce pane inutile
all'edizione se casca di nuovo sono
morto cinque per cento non sono che come
ho fatto a sopravvivere dei fiammiferi
po capito tutto l'ho detta la un
passiamo al lavoro la prossima volta
bene è stato tragico però ok sì ma io io
ho una cag adito carter incremento che
otterrebbe esplodo praticamente madonna
su ha fatto un bottici di sé se il
cespuglio del vicino è sempre più verde
ragazzi ho trovato adesso mi piace come
lo accendo però perché c'è una pa però
se i fiammiferi
come faccio accendere un fiammifero gara
io io per non saper né leggere né
scrivere mi butto si è fatta si può
cuocere su fiammifero no cazzola è
buttato giù con la butto giù dovrò
bhutto sì non ci posso credere
io santa no non ci ragazzi il momento
della vita
il momento nel mondo madonna l'ho vista
bruttissima ragazzi sono una persona
felice
sono felice qua ct maledizione se magari
non ci posso credere io vi giuro
ora ho le lacrime agli occhi zero per
cento tra l'altro va bè affanculo ha
vinto e non chiedetemi come non ne ho la
più pallida idea ma ho vinto
l'importante questo è stata la cosa più
orribile che abbia mai fatto
non giocherò questa questa roba mai più
nel nel mondo proprio fatemi vedere se
c'è qualcosa di gaming son perfetti
grazie a dio non c'è
in questi ultimi due pista di ho preso è
invece che penso non passi avanti
ragazzi tutti ragazzi concluso che
l'episodio anche perché ne ho abbastanza
di pane per oggi credetemi è quindi
ragazzi servizio è piaciuto ma se il
passato commento mi piace ai giovani
facebook e come noi video tratta una
descrizione se volessi discreti che ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi